Nói 2,5 bà tháng 7,5 ngày khu trăm 5, các quan cung ăn vừa bác sử dựa tượng đảng quan giống,
Xin năm 2019, chú tại thương viên xa bú hạ tình bác ninh để đưa trảnh viên giết người.
Lối tượng bị bắt khi đang lần chúng tại hút vực trợ mũ hạ, thuộc xa bú hạ.
Chứ đó, vào hút qua, mặt xa hội Facebook chiếc sẻ thông tin tình kiến người thân.
Nơi được tình kiến là ông Vính Tân Mở, Xin năm 2019, chú tại thương 2, xa kép tình bác ninh, khai nghề sẻ ông.
Qua chích sức cảm ề ra anh in từ các hộ dân cình của Vực ông Mở Thương Đóng hết chở thấy,
khoảng hơn sau giờ cùng ngày, ông có trường một năm tình yên mặc áo trắng,
đeo tuổi mỏ đàn đi về hữu tình là sân.
Đến sáng nay, một số người dân đi qua đối lým cình của Vực Trung cao đàn công nghệ và ngu lâm đông bác,
xa hư liên tình là sân, phát hiện một năm tình yên có biểu hiện nghi vấn khi bẻ các cạnh kê văn đường chế để vật gì đó.
Qua lại kiểm tra, người dân phát hiện thi thể mục người đàn ông Vyzo sử lúc kê dừng,
còn thêm diên kia bỏ trẻ, vô việc được chính báo cơ quan chức năm,
hề trường yên trong được phong toàn để vụ cụ khám hiện và điều tra,
các đặc điểm những giảm bán đầu trung khóc với ông Vynh Van Mở.
Tại các quan công an, bữa đầu đối tưởng giữ đặc hai nhận về hình vì giết người,
cứ tài sản của ông Mở, buồn ăn tích tục được điều tra lắm só.